i can't oh yes i remember where i was
last time i
was a boy wasn't i
that's where i left it i was like i'm a
boy now
wow wow time's changed
oh yeah after this game i'll be playing
a little nightmares too nikki
that got finished one game at a time i
know i'm a very slow
very slowly this is your world
show me what you're having major cthulhu
vibes
like major love love crafty and
everything looks like it comes from
under underwater it looks like algae
looks wet looks damp
weird shapes in the distance green
hues is this where it started richard
the place that broke you made you what
you want
oh look are there tentacles
in this is there tentacles in this game
man tells us tentacles anyway
massive hands too we saw we saw one of
those hands when we were the girl
let me know by the way if um voice to
game ratio
is not okay what am i supposed to be
doing oh rv
oh what are these things going to hurt
me not anymore
oh yeah i forgot to fix camera angles
i'm sure this hand will be nice oh it is
the big hands
nice it's just the little ones that
aren't very nice
okay
there's something here it awoke on the
day when she came to it
took over made itself at home
she came to it we're not here this is
not this is the house right
we didn't come here
loss hatred
grief this place
reeks of them
something terrible happened here
it changed richard forever
leave her alone
here's that this is it richard's big
ugly secret the sum of
all his demons
where are we are we and which
which are we and which house
are we in richard's house
oh yeah baby we got ourselves a knife
richard your father forgot his knife
you better go and bring all right i'll
play along
for now who the frick was that
i tried to like back out of that because
i thought someone was behind me talking
but no just turns out there's a random
voice over so instead i
skipped the voice that was kind of
annoying
okay we'll just carry on stop
complaining
love the tentacles father you forgot
your knife
thank you richard you know what
why don't you keep it oh scheisse that's
your lucky knife
and now it's yours you'll need it this
is richard
as a kid we're like leaving tomorrow
what
no
where are you going the army is heading
out west
and i'll be going with them but
no i don't want you to go
i love players i love little tiny stupid
things like that i don't want to go
either son
but sometimes what we want isn't what's
important
do you understand i
when will you come back take care of
your mother richard
you're the man of the house now he's not
coming back
okay so for some reason we're looking at
rich's childhood i don't know how that's
possible
but i guess we won't question
everything's possible in capuleo land
rexolite said uh trigger warning so
trigger warning trigger a twig
twigger warning why can i not say ours
today
jesus christ right by the sweat of your
brow
yes great wonderful lovely
anything else can i read these papers
was that literally it
no
oh yes my inside almost forgot
you shall rise and you shall fall
who's that is that his mum then perhaps
till you return to the earth from which
you came
for dust you are into dust
you will return
that was a bit spooky
[Music]
as government representative of the
polish republic
i wish to offer my deepest sympathy and
regret in regards to the passing of
lieutenant lieutenant thadius
takalski tarkowski is dead
he whose last you mourn died in the
noblest of causes
his country will be forever grateful for
his service
the sacrifice he has made protecting our
freedom and independence
his daddy died
grief anger oh
that's confident
those tentacles are guarding something
it's one powerful painting
okay then oh this is pretty
look at the plants we're going to a
hedge maze
i love hedge mazes hey richard
i bet you can't catch me
what hey wait up i'm gonna go the
obviously wrong way
i hope it's wrong
yes wrong way
come on richard my arms are getting
tired
almost done that's cute
arms are getting tired what are these
guys doing
come on slowpoke awkward jobs are on the
maze
wait
assembly together i'll try to bring more
tomorrow
thank you richard i can't tell you how
much this means to me
is he bringing bread to like
a homeless person
or what
okay uh this is different ways to go
keep looking around
this way silly
but what is it it's
something very important promise me
you'll keep it safe
what is it let me see i want to open it
why can't i open it
there's a fire should we keep going this
way is a dead end it's weird i'm walking
back on myself
oh hello okay let's go swim
where'd you go
uh this way
i think we've been yeah we went this way
uh
okay
he looks so out of place here like it's
just like
a weird goth dude
uh is there any way that i haven't been
i went down this way right
it's very cute painting it looks very
disney-esque
painting drawing
uh apparently richard told sadness about
this girl
no i don't remember that see is the only
problem about getting playing games once
a week
can you remind me of my job my memory
what did he say about this girl
what oh my god
there must be someone else somewhere
else but i forgot to look
let's get back in there
rexella is not a richard fan
i wish we could walk a little bit faster
or run a bit faster
okay
he told sadness she reminds him of a
girl who was special to him as a child
okay that's a bit creepy
i mean we already knew that it was
creepy anyway
the relationship that he had with
sadness is there nothing else i can look
at
really
oh no i don't need that
i've got nothing yay do you have that
knife
can i really not open this seems like
that's my next
port of call
okay
rose gross
over here
there you are i was afraid you'd get
lost
i did me i've been waiting here for
ages that's pretty i'm starting to get
bored waiting for you
hey
hey you see that i like how her name's
rosen has loads of roses
it's a big one we should probably go
same spot tomorrow i'll be there
but she wasn't
cute richard real cute
so where do we go from here
oh yeah because richard was an artist
wasn't he
very uh unique art style i'll give him
that
i guess we leave
everything sounds so wet
i can feel something's not right
fela i can bloody see it this is like
some sort of beard here can i cut it
with my knife i've got nothing
lies
mom who is he he's
he's someone who can take care of us but
i can take care of him i promise dad i
protect you
i know honey and he would be so proud of
you
but sometimes a brave heart is just not
enough
tear up i'm gonna turn down my lights a
little bit
there we go see better now
hey come here i need you to do something
for me
yes chad what would you like me to bring
that thing you know which one
yeah real specific the cushion the
pillow
i've got nothing
is it the chair talking to me or is it
the animated
freaking tentacle behind it oh it's so
creepy it's freaking
moving
it's following me don't like
can i read it let me read it
i want to read it find it
don't make me get up boy
this is dad before he went to the war
i kind of picked these things up my
inside's seen them
oh i think it wants the book all right
fair enough let me go
give him this book
oh i i got your phone what you want a
bedtime story
i'm not your goddamn mother
this is so weird
okay sorry you won the book okay i'll
get you something else
would you like uh a beer a cigarette
you probably want a beer don't you i
mean i'm guessing that's definitely what
you want you want to be it
you calling me a drunk get the hell away
with that
real [ __ ] charmer that one sorry
sorry
this is fun okay what else do i have to
choose from
uh oh does he want a smoke what's this
a jewelry case what what might you want
with this
oh you want to look fabulous okay i got
your jewelry right here don't worry
you're gonna look spiffy in just a
moment i put a little necklace over your
beautiful
uh tip oh you little [ __ ]
i'll teach you some respect
[Music]
oh oh okay fine i'll get you a pipe i
think that's what he wants this pipe
oh [ __ ] i don't think i can give him
anything now
i think i just have to like fight him
all right [ __ ]
that's what you get
i don't actually know what to do now i
think i've messed up
uh can i look back at the shelf please
i just i just like wanted to help him
look pretty and
he wouldn't take my outfit so
boom baby
just keep doing that maybe i've got to
get the chair
back together
can i hit it
ah what the hell did you do to me
fair enough you stayed back
oh god you again ungrateful little
[ __ ] get the hell away from me
gladly
damn
okay then i'm guessing he wouldn't have
liked anything that we gave him
[Music]
get away from me you factored no
no no
i like these because you can time it
well
oh god
okay yes serious trigger warning
it's all your fault
can't protect anyone he's gone
gone forever
you'll never be him never
ever ever little [ __ ]
worthless useless
no oh it sucks i can't feel bad for him
so
this place again but not the same
time it looks like it's uh
well at least a different season richard
nina said that wasn't his dad was that
really not rich's dad
richard where are you stepped out if
rich's dad went off to war then
i should be going i'm sorry
it's all right we can finish some other
time
god i gotta say it's it's quite hard to
follow a complex narrative when you're
live streaming
so sorry if i'm getting any of this
wrong and annoying you just let me know
and i'll correct myself hello
what's that here
oh to be fair probably get to explore
the whole thing anyway
richard come out dicky
wait i think i'm just going back the way
that i just came oh no
oh it was the necklace
i'll keep you safe
[Music]
this isn't funny
richard
there you are oh hey
i waited for you by the maze
i was afraid something happened to you
i'm
are you sure you're all right i said i'm
fine
hey if something happened
just let me get the hell away from me
i'm surmising he killed his stepdad if
that wasn't his dad
with a knife okay richard i get the
picture
doesn't change a goddamn thing
mommy thomas isn't what's going on
shh listen to me richard listen to my
every word
some men will come to her house tonight
but why what they want
it's okay i told them to come
the hell is this no just stay away from
me
just stay back
oh he didn't kill his stepdad i take it
back away from me you
bastards no no
he's not killing me
who the hell
trixolite says trigger warning again
any son of poland who collaborates with
the oppressor
the oppressor
oh my god i'm so freaking lost
narrative wise
i need to find a source of energy
who steals from denounces or
otherwise acts against his compatriots
right so he gave commits an
unforgivable crime against the
motherland
richard gave that girl a like a
religious symbol as a necklace then
first house on the left next right to
the river with the old cherry tree in
front
they're hiding them in the pantry under
the floorboards
they let them out sometimes stretch out
oh my god wait [ __ ]
is this what i think it is
this is about are they hiding like jews
and that was like the jewish symbol
right
so this girl that he fell in love with
was it was a jew and they were hiding
them
or well it says them but we've only
heard mention of
one girl but i guess there were more
damn damn damn damn
okay it's all coming together now
swiftly punished
couldn't happen to a nicer guy
[Music]
right
so what happened to her then i guess the
old oh god this is getting
tedious
do you not like the
[Music]
[ __ ]
maze
oh hell yeah die sucker
i like being this man it's less scary i
feel like i have more
more skill against them all right and
that's why he was giving her
food please come out she was in hiding
there you go cc
damn
let's go the other way
please i need you for fun
i didn't see them
you oh he didn't die but whatever
froze
go rose please wake
up wake up
uh crap where do i go now
is that not a path because that looks
like a path okay
oh
he took her from me
what the frick is that noise
you took her from me
a little t-rex
i feel like i'm getting lost
oh okay turn around
this way
this way
oh crap
here
just bear with me people
oh you guys at end
hey leon
oh i nearly got me then
back here again i guess i'll just oh
[ __ ] off i'll just keep going until i
i kill you uh i did it too early
least he doesn't run out of his insight
power whatever the hell it is
hey leaves
[Music]
i'm stuck in amaze
can i go this way yeah
oh what's this oh i want to get through
here
why it looks like i should be able to go
through there
oh god i am actually really lost aren't
i
you have my insight
i swear i came through this way
some places get closed off while i was
searching
no
oh
oh
maybe we just go back out the way we can
oh this is it whoa
what is that
no here
not rose
what is that you
what
no
i lily
that's so weird i didn't think richard
could see anything
thanks dinamod i escaped the maze i
am pro
and we have just
restored our power
okay
hey hello hello hamel
oh we're gonna go out and talk to that
thing i just wanna talk i don't i don't
wanna
fight it i just wanna talk to it's too
scary to fight
[Music]
oh let's get this over
okay i guess
how jesus
my controller is vibrating like crazy
stop
[Applause]
oh
my god
help somebody
please help
monster you say
and what does this
monster look like sir
there's no time hurry we have to get out
of here
it's okay richard why don't you take a
moment to
catch your breath do
i know you mister are you one of my
stepfather's
friends
no kid stepfather yeah
i'm not planning on making any friends
i'm here just
for you what no don't come any closer
don't judge me i'm sorry kid
i know you tried to run to hide get your
hands off me
as long as you're in here the beast
will always find you
richard
[Music]
damn it was pretty overwhelming at first
thomas being like me but different
somehow
i guess i don't have to tell you
you
thomas is
um
instead he chose to rot in this
godfather
[Music]
you're him richard
excuse me what you smell
oh disgusting like the girl who suffered
because of you
is the one you prayed upon she came
[Music]
oh shut up stop acting like you ever
cared about her
your soul has brought it away
there's barely anything left i know
it's just your sins i almost feel sorry
for you
you're nothing
a monster what are you
this man thomas
what is he
[Music]
you don't deserve it you deserve
nothing nothing do you hear me
then give it to me please
do not exist that's all i
want who wants to
[Music]
i'm not your judge i'm just the fairy
man
be gone
richard dicky
yeah what the hell did he mean by that
this time
it wasn't just a feeling
it was a memory
had i been here before
was i a part of the puzzle
yes man thomas
was he
[Music]
a part of my own past
what are you gonna say to sadness when
you see her next
you found out so much
and then something clicked
all right computer
that girl it's me
but it looks like it was taken here well
done
you're so far behind all of us but you
got there in the end
it's a red house
whatever it is i can feel it out there
like it's calling out to me
there in the woods
red house
oh spooky okay
well well done we did something
even though richard totally deserved
those demons but
you know for eternity is a very long
time
and he still has to get judged anyway so
that signpost which way do we want to go
is it all dead ends
another postcard
hello my sunshine working hard as always
mr wreckabridge says there won't be any
more guests coming but that's all right
still plenty i can help with him with i
just wish it was quiet
why won't it stop talking i really wish
i could see you
uh this if i remember is francis
the groundskeeper and he never sent this
postcards to his wife he was like
getting tested on or something right
how is he no don't put him on i'm still
at work
just tell me if he's okay all right
tell them i'll be back soon hmm
this one felt subdued
like if someone lit a match in a giant
freezer
oh guess not
the written link ad
reclaiming history a late 19th century
thought of a great historical
significance will soon be renovated
and reopened to the public the works are
expected to start next year
so are we going to go through a rubble
of the fort
great great great oh can we see here
what's go oh my god this [ __ ] bird
i'm getting um
what's it called ah what's that
hurricane cause
and it's it's got all the your bog
standard horror tropes until dawn i'm
getting until dawn flashbacks here
you know when you like look through the
little binoculars near the start of the
game and then it's
boom and someone just jumps up that
doesn't seem to be happening here
that's good
there was just that uh bird
but that's okay we can handle birds okay
yeah
there's nothing to see
my darling have you ever mentioned mr
beckerwich's daughter
liliane that's her freaking name
is it is mr breckerwitch is that thomas
brekkerwich
maybe not she turns 16 today probably
not no that's way too
way too old poor thing couldn't even
have a proper birthday
because of that sickness she's got no
anyway remind me about anna herrera's is
next month
isn't it i wish i could be there but mr
beckerbitch needs me here gotta say
gotta help him out like he helped me
hello
hello educational trail
yeah sadness is super cool i like
sadness
she doesn't creepy though i always i
wonder if she's kind of rotting away a
bit
more each time we see her if so that's
really cool but also i
worry for her arm it looks like it's
going to fall off any moment now
it sounded familiar somehow something
from my early childhood maybe
was it even a place or something else
entirely
red trees
what a beautiful tree oh [ __ ]
does this mean it's here somewhere
because i remember that flashing light
is kind of like in silent hill with the
um
oh radio words
the hell it's just around this tree that
my light starts to flicker
spooky ass tree i guess
nothing i can do with it
okay i will leave the tree
there anything up this way what's that
noise
my dearest it's getting harder and
harder to ignore it
worst of all it's starting to make sense
that girl
that poor girl locked up like an animal
no child should live like this is she
really that sick
mr brekkovich says it's for her own good
but i'm starting to wonder
i wish i could see you again i love you
so much
hmm
okay so let's go back
oh vixela i heard that um
yeah that the uh was it designer or
director or something of siren and the
old i think it was silent hill one and
two
maybe three but yeah i heard um he was
making the game i didn't know it was
gonna be for next year that's pretty
cool my star sign is
taurus one move one move
for the times we cried one move
sorry
siren was a freaking terrifying game
oh thanks for hosting denise
yes siren was so scary i played it
i played it as a child i really
shouldn't have
um my dad got me this ps2 demo
uh disc with a bunch of game demos on it
and siren was one of those demos and it
was
absolutely bloody terrifying even just a
different
demo it looks like it
another one rotted from the inside this
is the first one we've seen do they miss
one
uh i guess under here
what that bread just doesn't care i
thought it was gonna fly off when we ran
under her but nope
it's just staring at us these animals
they look
used up like something sucked the life
out of them
voldemort but now he only does that with
um
unicorns
get the [ __ ] out of me little buddy
yay you must be a fly witch do you guys
remember playwitch
oh i miss having a dog that we could pet
when we feel scared he's got a hairbrush
oh he's thinking about us in our career
oh no it's a [ __ ] i never never mind
wait
yeah i don't think we can be uh brushing
our hair with that
we could try probably
all right all right
but i kind of want to check out the
river but i guess i'll follow you
shush um
there i was following my new best friend
hoping he wasn't as lost as i was i
remember thinking he could lead me to
his owner
in a way i guess he did
oh let's find out yeah i'm enjoying this
game so far denise
um it's got some stealth elements that
i'm not not a massive fan of
uh mainly because of the way the level
design is set up i just find it quite
difficult to navigate the space
especially with the fixed camera angles
but
everything else the narrative is really
intriguing i freaking love the whole
multi-dimension especially when the
spleen the screen splits and the
cinematics of this game
so freaking cool
uh is this where we go buddy can i can i
hit you
what's wrong buddy
wait oh let's see what we got here
yummy let's feed the dogs such a
throwback to blair witch
which is also a blue boutine game so
yeah
we've been able to feed both the cat and
the dog in this game best game
yes
what is it boy you want to show me
something
you catch a scent hey
anyone in there
that's wrong
is someone in there i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
i hello you so much oh
why did i stay why did i
let it out they're all dead i'm
still here i shouldn't
be hey
you all right now you shouldn't be
i can see you
is this like his demon now
whatever this dude did
guessing this one that's been killing
all the deers
what of course dead man
what else did you expect marianne
dead man
dead man
killed himself or killed by someone else
he looks drained
yeah rotted out from within
just like those animals i saw earlier
wait is this the caretaker
i think that's him after they closed
down the resort
did he just stay behind yeah it's
francis what is it boy
was he your friend oh was
[Music]
oh hello
he's got such big hands
all i wanted was for her to see the sun
wait did he try and help that girl
escape
or something because
i'm guessing that's who he's referring
to as her and seeing the sun because she
was always locked up right
and then was he killed by mr rakovich
easy boy what is it
yeah bullet
show us where the danger is it's that
thing again
no no no no no no no no no no i don't
like these
yeah that's really gonna help
yes
stay the [ __ ] away from me
let me draw you on i'm too small for ya
let's do the running secret
i love how she loaded in there oh [ __ ]
you cannot stop me i'm running so fast
he's not shiny where'd you get that
information from
don't leave me here
oh here's the ruins
oh shiny because she looks new to the
mall
i read that pixelate as shiny because
she looks new to me ma
like me more like mumsy
oh that was nice it was nice to have a
little doggo back
just for a little second got to reuse um
bullet from blair witch cube
just re-skin him a little bit
anything abuse around here
no okay
oh my god slenderman what
who's there you
promise what did i promise
no risky stuff
oh this isn't
real oh my god
hey dad step jack
thanks for hosting danny
the rain also makes her shiny i guess we
could say this yes
so
hmm
i didn't do anything no i
i helped him to the other side he
shouldn't be here anymore
if anyone's confused you haven't watched
the beginning of the game that was
our father figure like basically the guy
who brought her up but
she's not too sure where she came from
um
and he died at the beginning of the game
but she
took him to like the afterlife she
helped him pass on so
where have you sent me he shouldn't be
here
i i've helped you pass on
[Music]
no i know that's what i'm telling them
it's all your fault
jack it's too late
he wouldn't be like this
he was really nice oh it's them
how is that there
he's gone now when she looks back
oh no i just looked at the chat
in me
this won't hold it for long move your
ass
ah that's so creepy
naughty daddy oh god
that sound effect literally just sounds
like someone just got
into the microphone and just put a lot
of reverb and echo on it
hey eggsy
anything here he's gonna come back soon
i'm not prepared for it
i need to get some water i drink so much
when i'm on stream
okay well at least we know it wasn't um
our naughty daddy so we don't have to
worry about
having sent him to the wrong place
generator
i wonder if it still works oh well i
highly doubt of course it doesn't
i think it's out of gas
okay so we need to find some gas
somewhere
lock down tight i think there's a lever
missing
okey-dokey
oh is that
[Music]
music music
there you go
there is something
don't fail me now
[ __ ] that was loud
where the hell are we going oh no no
no no
[Music]
oh
oh
oh my god come on you're literally at
the edge just jump or something
okay
can we chuck this brick on its head
we'll just use the water to time it
right
oh no i'm making too much noise i don't
like it
oh gosh stop
oh god no not these plants okay i really
hate these parts i'm really not very
good at these parts i
freaking hate these parts
oh [ __ ] the birds
i'm in a shitty ear right let's go
oh my god how did it not see me
i don't know but i shouldn't really
question oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god just hide
can i this is what i hate about it it
looks like i can hide in there but i
can't
why couldn't i go behind it's fine it
didn't see me
stay here
i've panicked stay here and you'll be
fine
just need it to move
is it gonna move ever
it's not is that
okay
how am i gonna do this i need to get
over there
oh what do i i want to do more things
come on
yeah i thought i was i thought i was
going to make something drop in his head
but you know that'll do as well i guess
that wasn't too hard that's my way out i
think i'd give it too much credit that
thing in my way maybe
i don't know he's quite scary
you don't know jack
[Music]
did you send him here
[Music]
no not jack
no this is so creepy
i don't like it
so
at least this could come in handy
okay
it's very descriptive what you're afraid
of
energy's energy
yeah let the energy within you i guess
are we safe now hey i'm almost back at
the generator
that's nice
[Music]
that um music tells me no
honestly this is why i stream horror
games denise because i am
also a wuss and i could not play on my
own
so don't worry
i totally understand
um but yeah troy baker just doesn't
sound like him does it
so crazy uh let's do
done
now what can we do
oh right we need to open the gates that
would help
what that was for
still down there
to me
[Music]
no thank you shot your [ __ ] mouth
[Music]
yes is it dead
can it die is it dead
can i go in the water now so many
questions okay i can go to the water
god i hope this is over
me too
no offense toy baker but you creepy
hey clay
here we go back out again
into the wilderness
so we're getting we're gonna try and
find this little red house
what is that sounds like
what do you think it sounds like guys
i actually don't know uh
oh it's sadness
sadness
sadness is that you oh
hi marianne did you find what you were
looking for
i was hoping you could tell me
sadness
i need you to focus
think back to as far as you can remember
what do you see is this a game
yes i'm afraid not hon oh
okay this is important
listen i know
what richard did
was he the one keeping you here mary
again
it's okay i've sent him away
he's gone forever
lily lily yeah it is lillian
that used to be your name do you
remember
all that's happened your father
you remember him
i remember mommy
was so pretty but
but so sad just like
you it must be nice
to remember your mommy
i never met my parents they
they we were
in an accident when i was very little
i was the only one who made it
it was really lonely without them
i know what that's like
ever since my friends
this is a lonely place marianne
i shouldn't be here i want to see the
face
under the mask you'd be better off
somewhere else
maybe i could send me away
no marianne i can't leave
not yet but why
aren't you afraid of the monster
oh great it's not dead is it
i am
but it doesn't need me
anymore
it wants you and
when when it breaks you
when it puts you on it
it'll finally be able to leave this
place
but it it will
never be full it will never stop
killing then let me send you away
so we can both leave now that you
remember who you
are i can no marianne
it's not just about me
it's you you
the fire
the red house
there it is what
wait what is the red house you were
there marianne
with me you were
always with me what
i'm so sorry
lily
what what
i'm so confused
we'll find out i guess that's the
confusing conversation
just when i thought i could finally send
her away
can i thomas i really hope you're still
out here
i'm running out of options
oh
ah the spark's too weak to absorb
it's like it's missing something
are you looking for this little girl um
i'm sorry but um father doesn't like it
when i talk to strangers
smart man he's the manager around here
right
this is mystery do you ever know where
he is
i'd love to have a word with him maybe
go away
or i'll scream clever girl
mm-hmm who was that then was that
francis or
i don't know okay there's something up
top
thomas look you were here
this was your place
what the red house looks just like a
garage
bogey what we're gonna use this for
i guess for um
sadness a little present
this looks like it could lift a pound or
two
it's missing a handle
richard how could you do it how the [ __ ]
can anyone do such a thing
i guess deep down i always knew there
was something broken inside you but
this one thing's certainly
whatever he did to you whatever we did
to you
you got what you deserved thank you for
subscribing surreal
something around here that we can
let's be somewhere else
you're one to talk this is your bright
idea
no they're already onto us that son of a
[ __ ] is one of them i can feel it
fine we'll make sure come on
it's almost on one of them
who are you running from thomas
what the hell happened here oh
state player
july 27 1983
the gemini case the investigation is
moving along
but i think rekkovich is starting to
suspect something
need to move fast tonight's the night
so they knew about thomas
but how much exactly and who the hell
were they okay yeah so this was someone
entirely different he was trying to talk
to sadness
but luckily she told them to go
away okay let's um
go do our thing how do we do this again
hence the red house right
that makes sense
we should find something
something we can use as a leather
ah
it can't be that far away surely
i'm gonna
can we interact with this thing the
power's out
oh there are stairs here
oh and there's a bike oh hey
a yonak someone's got good taste
look at you showing off with your bike
knowledge
[Music]
there's something under that oh there it
is
if only i could lift it somehow
okay
all right so we need to get the
that top generator how do we get up
there then
find those boxes can i do something
can i climb this broken ladder
here
hmm
oh no i need to find something
to give us more power again
darn it that is right but
we don't have something that we need
what do we need
i don't know
the doll
my brain just suddenly clicked in gear
oh i can just do it from out here
i thought we were keeping the dollars a
little present
but that makes much more sense
oh [ __ ] the thing's unstable
i can't keep it running for too long
what oh fine
okay okay okay okay all right i'll get
myself in position
i have to be very quick then i guess
oh
there we go
don't let it drop on your head or
something
okay go go
oh good i thought when the engine cut
out that i might just be like
that would not be good that'd be the
best
okay now we can go out to the red house
was this the red house
it was then
this was the place the answers were
right in front of me buried among the
ashes
there's gotta be something left
i'm just gonna be
extra careful and go back and get some
more power just in case we need
power just in case that weird monster
comes back
wait not that way
thank you very much
okay so we can't go into the house
that's a shame i wanna
maybe we can maybe we can do something
to stop the fire
you think you're tough when you hear
them squeal and you smell their bodies
burning you'll tell me everything
you beg me to listen
or she was i
i'm trying to remember the beginning
sequence now because she had this
memory almost didn't she being chased
through the forest
they did it on purpose
goddamn freaks you think you're so
special
you'll burn just like the rest of
[ __ ] is that us well there was thomas
and there was her
was that like a was it like x-men
the school of like
super power people
let's take
okay let's see who you really are
[ __ ]
you want to give it a go be my guest
this one's all yours i'd like to think
i'm more of the
brains of the operation
hey i got an idea why don't we
or that yeah
i guess right
what do we have here
[ __ ] i knew he was trouble
security service
[ __ ]
that's no way to talk about a government
agent comrade
wake up comrade socialism ain't gonna
build itself
that was a funny sound [ __ ]
you don't know who you're messing with
kids oh
but i do i've spent a lot of
time getting to know you thomas
in fact you're kind of uh that project
of mine
oh yeah what's my speedo sound
funny guy i love this one
you like it too comrade [ __ ] you
let's play a game it's called
what makes thomas dick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
the nazis
found you in warsaw when you were what
three years old they were gonna kill you
[Music]
the war's over in
comes the heroic red army
and they locked me up for years
[ __ ] savages
they do important scientific
research find out what it is
and what is that exactly ask your mom
you enjoy it don't you
hurting people like those scientists
who were you 18
i saw the photographs
i know how to make a man
hurt but i gotta say i wasn't impressed
stick around i'll give you a live
demonstration
and there you were free at last but
always on the run and look at you
almost made it but you had to use this
powers again
on your best friend richard
i know you wanted revenge i understand
i would do anything for my child too it
takes
leave my children out of this
children yes
how much pain would you endure to keep
them
children what would you sacrifice for
them
your freedom maybe let me go
you piece of [ __ ] that's what i thought
i'll let you go but first
i want you to tell me all about these
powers ears then earn it
come on enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
hit me i thought you'd never ask
get some rest thomas the next time you
wake
up the real pain begins
[ __ ]
thomas is our dad sadness is autistic
wake up sleepyhead time's
running
here
you're still in there thomas you
show me now
what was he doing taking that guy to the
other side
yeah i guess i
[ __ ] finally i thought he'd never
give us a chance
okay gotta move fast
thankfully this place has a way of
messing with the time flow
i still got a chance to save them
pause i need to just go get some more
water
be right back talk about yourselves have
fun see you soon
i'm back
this is quick
okay let's carry on
oh work and no play are you henry
all right let's see what makes
you tick
i'm guessing it by the end are we by the
end guys
press x to use no way across
guess i'll just make my own
[Applause]
[ __ ] i'm not alone in here
oh it's not the end okay in that case
i'll probably go in a bit then
i thought it was the end let's see if we
can get
past here
this looks so cool
and there's something scary around
i love how i'm i said like i'm probably
gonna go see if it's not the end nikki's
like
yes it's the end no nikki
it's okay i'm gonna finish it on
valentine's day
i don't know why i just didn't either
that's my intention anyway
so anything to check out here
there you are at least the part of you
i'm after
why do you sound so creepy dude
that's a kiss
butcher oh maybe not no no no
it's not jacob wilke
suspected of theft ford
illegal trade
cool can i watch it
oh yes
do you know why you're here oh it's
audio i'm not
playing your games henry
don't call me that
the agency was led to believe you've
been stealing meat from the working
people
of the republic
where would they get that idea i wonder
you've been a very bad boy
let's just get this over with
given your line of work you had ample
opportunity to commit your crime
it is a crime against the people
punishable by death
anything to say in your defense
i'm sorry henry
oh the door's open i swear the door was
closed just now
there hasn't been any kind of like
spatial jump scares in a while that's a
bit creepy
seeing that coat there like that
it's the librarian's dog
[ __ ] you're right
oh a bit of a janky fall
meet grindr oh disgusting
rations
hmm
this is inside i guess
inside the head of the dude who
has held thomas captive
i can't do anything here can we
no not yet
oh [ __ ]
oh he doesn't crouch he doesn't even
care
he's like yeah whatever there you are
yeah i'm here
i know you're come here
i'm not scared of you oh maybe i am
[ __ ] that's weird i think i'm gonna die
why can't i don't shall hide from me
i'm not hiding thomas is too cool to
crouch and i don't know why
oh [ __ ]
he's gonna come here next week
here we go cool to crouch
oh god i don't like this place
i go for like morning walks and i walk
past like a
butcher's and sometimes they see them
like reel out
the um yeah like the carcasses and stuff
and i'm like
cool cool nice
[Music]
ah thanks for stopping by so so
bendy be even though you're working i
want to
is that dead person here
what this is a random person
okay
[Music]
tiny baby steps tiny
tiny baby steps thomas tiny baby steps
against
okay
his childhood was spent in like a
slaughterhouse
learning how to cut things
[Music]
where are you boys again
even emotions against the
emotions
you know i like jumping into people's
kind of like jumping into their heads
jumping into like the darker side of
themselves i guess it kind of is that
way is their heads really in it it's a
bit like psychonauts
excited for that game
i think in australia there was this
woman who was a butcher she ended up
murdering and eating her husband
what oh my gosh
that's actually terrifying if that is
true
oh no this does not look nice
good that's good
see how easy it is when you do
as you're told i was literally just
saying oh it hasn't been many jump
scares
patriotism stronger than blood not often
do we see patriotism as such quality as
we displayed during these past weeks by
senior constable
henry wilke a simple officer of the
civic police
wilkes showed his commitment to building
a righteous tomorrow of the people's
republic by rejecting the shackles of
his criminal kinship
his daring investigation into the now
infamous meat scandal
ah meat scandal led to
a number of arrests including one jacob
wilk
henry's own father oh my god
he had to arrest his own dad jesus
christ the irregularities uncovered by
officer wilk included corruption theft
of high quality meat products and
replacing them for lesser ones
apart from jacob wilke numerous other
couplets have been apprehended
including four directors of the
socialized meat trade and several store
managers
trial is segments this coming thursday
and if the accused are found guilty of
their crimes they will most likely face
execution by hanging
damn that is a
severe punishment when asked for comment
officer henry wilkes response was simple
i did what i felt just
truly the words of a patriot
steady hand even emotions against the
grain
never with against the grain
i guess uh can i have a look at the
other thing all right
well done i guess
this is the same thing you want me to
feel sorry for you henry
let's see how that works out yeah i mean
he
didn't feel sorry for richard so
bad chance
oh what a cute mug oh
vilk is it henry vilk
what's this about
straight to the point no fear
no hesitation
if you wanted me dead i'd be dead
already
so what do you want
i want to offer you a job
i'm listening i've been doing this a
long time
i've come to know people see what makes
them
tick see there
potential agreed
on one condition huh
the work i do for you it stays at work
that's the way we like it
it has to if it doesn't
i'll just kill you
welcome to the family
great family much love
there we go
ugh
that sounds cool
thomas said she isn't fazed by anything
he doesn't care
he's just trotting
[Music]
no sign of like whoa what's that noise
oh i gotta be careful
he's just like
and then he's just like making the most
noise not giving a crap
librarians don't like that
have you ever heard of neva
special assignment for major henry vilk
a person of interest has been found at
neva workers resorts
near krakow local investigators had
reported of a strange case involving the
painter
the past richard the person was found
alive but in a vegetative
state foul play was suspected
but examination didn't show signs of
brain trauma
possible connection to the gemini case
keep it clean keep it quiet this is what
we've been training you for
note i strongly recommend that you
acquaint yourself with the soviet
scientist notes
we acquired during classified
in 1950 you've been granted access to
archives entry 1138
this is for your eyes only
dig in report to your case officer
for further briefing
so they knew what happened to richard
but did they know what richard did
though
what's this test subject
the subject continues to manifest strong
supernatural powers
he claims that another something is
talking to him showing visions
working theory suspected connection to
something possibly establish the results
of a near-death experience
more tests necessary to confront the
split theory so either it's
thomas when he was getting um
you know tested on or someone like
thomas i'm guessing it's thomas because
henry said that he'd been looking into
him
i kind of feel like i should stop
because it's getting late
but
it's weird
yeah this is all going to be thomas's
today's session halted prematurely due
to an incident in the test chamber
while administering prescribed sentences
lee scientist
came into skin to skin contact with the
subject
he was promptly hospitalized despite
showing no sign of physical trauma he
fell
into a vegetative state for which he's
yet to recover
further sessions have been halted
infinitely
indefinitely
[Music]
he's just reading stuff he doesn't care
um reminder for today's rescheduled
session despite increased dosage
the subject remains extremely dangerous
and needs to be restrained both
physically and mentally for the duration
of the test
heightened security measures apply
okay see thomas just about us like
literally doesn't care
gigantic demon monsters
like i'm even going to bat an eyelid
there you go okay he does care cares a
little bit
so
are we gonna move that whole thing
[ __ ] not good not good okay we'll do it
then
i'll be [ __ ] hurt
these um walking sequences are weird
i don't know what it is that makes them
start to like
tremble it's a lot of the time it's
using
the right analog stick to balance
yourself but it
i don't know
whoa jesus christ
uh which way
oh my god
he's so powerful so much power
listen here hey i'm walking here
i'm not getting [ __ ]
can't get me up here can you
stop being such a tease dude
and stay the [ __ ] down
right now
that was weird it took a while for the
camera to change there
oh no no not the door okay again
anyone look at this mom
daddy me why is the dad
red and he's in a wheelchair
okay
i'm going away tonight um
business trip short notice couldn't be
helped
say goodbye to him i'm
not sure if that's a good idea i have
work
on my mind i see
and again maybe i should do you think i
should yes henry
[Music]
simon where are you boy that's a wooden
dad
are you going away again daddy has to go
to work
once i get back i'll go fishing you'd
like that wouldn't you
i don't like it when you go i know
but sometimes daddy needs to work it's
good for all of us
you
okay i yes father
don't worry kid this will all be over
soon
thomas you're so damn heartless
oh my god this game has got some really
cool moments
visually it's so good
there he is
this is it you made it you're just in
time
it's got mohawk that's right kid just
come to me
i'll put an end to it i'll set you free
no it won't let us leave the monsters
don't worry about the monster kid
i'll deal with it i'll put it down for
good
not if it puts you down first what did
you say
a guilty conscience
oh my god
your tracks won't work on me oh man
[Music]
[Music]
but if we are one of the children then
we escaped
daddy
marianne
you see ya see she remembers
but that guy isn't dead yet
and he has no remorse
i remember
it's him it was always him
oh is it's you
you tried to kill us
what did you do to her
what did you do to lillian
i was already dead
well i mean you did burn his house with
his two doors inside
then who was it who killed her
i saw her go what happened to her
what the hell are you talking about
he wanted to save us to save her
that's exactly what he did
grief
suffering
he really is like a t-rex
then it's about time to clean it up
once for all
thomas rekovich
was he the man on the pier the man with
the gun
yeah exactly that's exactly what i was
thinking you're from my dream
everybody why
i needed to know what happened after the
fire
what happened to them
and is he dead because she got that
phone call
damn
loki wanted to fight that monster though
oh god okay so he's told her that
thomas tried to kill her and her sister
and he was the one
that chased her through the woods with a
gun because henry was already dead
apparently so it couldn't have been
henry jeez
jeez wow
i think that is a good place to
stop the game uh thank you
so much for watching and joining me
tonight
uh we got we got through quite a lot of
that i feel i feel i think
the next time we play i'm hoping so uh
i mean nina much nina mutt
uh can probably tell us but i think the
next time we play we might actually
finish it
and the next time will be on sunday so
i'm going to stream on sunday
uh from about one ish until about
seven ish uh that's gmt
uh one in the afternoon until seven in
the afternoon so
yeah it should be some good fun i'm
hoping i can finish the medium and then
we can just have some
chatting play some music
and i'll be playing among us with my
friends
as well so
yeah it should be a good day
nice nina said we'll we'll finish soon
yeah i think maybe just like a couple of
hours left
so yeah we can start the next live
stream playing this
and then uh we can chat and stuff
afterwards
and then play some among us it should be
fun so join me
on youtube or on twitch on sunday
uh where you can see the end of this
game
but thank you so much for watching i
hope you
are enjoying this and don't worry nikki
i will be playing
a little nightmares two straight after
this game so if i finish it on sunday
then you'll get that game
next week